其他人：这个谱子好啊
Others: This sheet music is good.
其他人：我觉得很适合
Others: I think it's very suitable.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Shure: 再弹一遍
Shure: Play it again.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：我靠牛啊
Others: Wow, that's impressive.
其他人：来吧
Others: Let's go.
其他人：这搞的好厉害
Others: This is really amazing.
其他人：我你妈搞这个音色
Other: What the heck is this sound?
其他人：感觉不如第一个
Other: Doesn't feel as good as the first one.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
其他人：不如啥
Other: Not as good as what?
其他人：不如第一个那个
Other: Not as good as the first one.
其他人：存放型确实也不够
Other: The storage capacity is definitely not enough.
其他人：哎这个行这个行
Other: Hey, this one works, this one works.
其他人：操这都不用自己弹
Other: Damn, you don't even have to play it yourself.
Tasha: 进吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
其他人：哦完全不一样
Other: Oh, it's completely different.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
其他人：这些都是你重新
Other: Did you get all of these again?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought them.
其他人：他妈的你都不知道他有多少个快递
Other: Dude, you have no idea how many packages he has.
其他人：我操
Other: Holy crap.
Tasha: 你自己来看嘛
Tasha: Come see for yourself.
Tasha: 你来看来看来看
Tasha: Come on, come see, come see.
其他人：又不是我的东西
Other: It's not even my stuff.
Tasha: 谢哥谢哥
Tasha: Thanks bro, thanks bro.
其他人：又不是我的东西OK
Other: It's not even my stuff, okay.
Tasha: 挑一件走
Tasha: Pick one and take it.
其他人：你把那个jelly cat挑走
Other: Take that jelly cat.
其他人：这就是我未来的梦想
Other: This is my future dream.
Tasha: 你未来的梦想啊
Tasha: Your future dream, huh.
其他人：来首二泉映月
Other: Let's play "The Moon Reflected in Erquan."
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: This one.
其他人：这jelly cat吗
Other: This jelly cat?
Tasha: 这不是啊
Tasha: No, it's not.
Tasha: 哪有这么多
Tasha: There's so many.
Tasha: 这一一长串啊
Tasha: It's a whole bunch.
Tasha: 这送给你女朋友
Tasha: This is for your girlfriend.
Tasha: 真的我跟你说这个
Tasha: Really, I'm telling you.
Shure: 人工智能直接增进了一个环境
Shure: AI directly enhanced an environment.
Shure: 怎么能如此的呢
Shure: How can it be so?
其他人：谢谢姐谢谢姐过几天来拿
Other: Thanks sis, thanks sis, I'll come get it in a few days.
其他人：你是我姐
Other: You're like my sister.
其他人：怎么调音效
Other: How do you adjust the sound?
Shure: 我再给你调哈哈哈
Shure: I'll adjust it for you, haha.
Tasha: 装饰完了
Tasha: All decorated.
Alice:真可爱
Alice: So cute.
Shure: 你知道那150个ego花了多少钱吗
Shure: Do you know how much those 150 egos cost?
其他人： 这什么东西啊
Others: What's that?
其他人：ego币
Others: Ego coins.
其他人：花多少钱150
Others: How much did 150 cost?
其他人：400人民币
Others: 400 RMB.
其他人：就为了150个虚拟货币
Others: Just for 150 virtual coins?
其他人：它跟比特币是一个
Others: It's similar to Bitcoin.
其他人：我们今天的活动赋予它价值
Others: Our activity today gave it value.
Shure: 了
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: （歌词）忘今宵难忘今宵
Shure: (lyrics) Unforgettable tonight.
Shure: （歌词）无论天涯
Shure: (lyrics) No matter where.
Shure: （歌词）哒哒哒哒
Shure: (lyrics) Da da da da.
其他人：这个音色真好
Others: This voice sounds so good.
其他人：这音色不
Others: This voice is not...
其他人：这个音色不好
Others: This voice doesn't sound good.
其他人：不适合吗
Others: Is it not suitable?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈太牛逼了
Shure: Hahaha, this is awesome!
其他人：这我都快掉下来
Others: I'm about to fall off.
其他人：来首富士山下
Others: Let's sing "Under Mount Fuji."
其他人：富士山下草原
Others: Under Mount Fuji, grassland.
其他人：修硕接一下修硕接一下
Others: Shure, take over, Shure, take over.
Shure: 等一下等一下
Shure: Wait a minute, wait a minute.
其他人：哎呦我操
Others: Oh my god.
Shure: （歌词）橱窗上表达的浪漫
Shure: (lyrics) The romance expressed on the window.
其他人：这音色怎么还一会变一下
Others: Why does this voice keep changing?
Shure: （歌词）星光拥有
Shure: (lyrics) The starlight possesses.
Shure: （歌词）接近花瓣铺满散了
Shure: (lyrics) Approaching the scattered petals.
Shure: （歌词）繁琐褪去
Shure: (lyrics) The complexity fades away.
Shure: （歌词）拥有要拥有必先多失
Shure: (lyrics) To have, one must lose a lot first.
Shure: （歌词）goes the both of love
Shure: (lyrics) Goes the both of love.
Shure: （歌词）谁又何妨不去
Shure: (lyrics) Who cares not to go.
其他人：唱不来一点
Others: Can't sing a bit.
其他人：来一首十年
Others: Sing "Ten Years."
Shure: 这是不是有点
Shure: Is this a bit...
其他人：不太对
Others: Not quite right.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
其他人：多搞笑 的事情吗
Others: Is this a funny thing?
其他人：就是造了150个币
Others: It's just about creating 150 coins.
Shure: 我着急花了400块钱
Shure: I was in a rush and spent 400 yuan.
Shure: 呦
Shure: Yo.
其他人：哎呀再弹点啥呢
Others: Oh, what else should we play?
其他人：又什么经典曲子
Others: Another classic piece?
Shure: 经典曲子
Shure: A classic piece.
Shure: 对一步之遥
Shure: Yes, "One Step Away".
Shure: 这必须得把弦乐组给你配上
Shure: We definitely need the string section for you.
Lucia: 有没有哪位同学个子比较高
Lucia: Is there any student here who's tall?
Lucia: 来帮我粘一个东西
Lucia: Can you help me stick something up?
Lucia: 谢谢你高人
Lucia: Thank you, tall person.
Lucia: 谢谢你高人高
Lucia: 就是这个这个鱼
Lucia: It's this, this fish.
Lucia: 呃踩吧踩吧没事哈哈
Lucia: Uh, step on it, it's fine, haha.
Shure: 什么哎呀
Shure: What, oh man.
Shure: 这就是一个宿主软件
Shure: This is just a host software.
Shure: 然后他把发送过去的MIDI信号
Shure: Then it sends the MIDI signal over.
Shure: 可以转换成音频信号
Shure: It can convert it into audio signals.
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome.
其他人：这不会是你做的吧
Others: This isn't your creation, right?
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 这怎么可能
Shure: How could it be?
Shure: 这是Logic
Shure: This is Logic.
Shure: （歌词）sometimes the memory was winding by
Shure: (Lyrics) Sometimes the memory was winding by.
其他人：实在不行我都拿小本本记账得了
Others: If it doesn't work, I'll keep track of it in a notebook.
Lucia: 我也有点怕你要不多多贴一点
Lucia: I'm a bit scared too, why not stick more of it?
其他人：靠他妈的跌了10块钱
Others: Damn, I lost 10 bucks.
Shure: 我哪个服务器
Shure: Which server of mine...
Shure: 又他妈没钱了
Shure: is out of money again, damn it.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Ugh.
Lucia: 那个专门放在中间就是
Lucia: That one's supposed to hang in the middle.
Lucia: 哈哈那个专门中间让他耷拉下来的
Lucia: Haha, it's meant to droop down in the middle.
Shure: 我赶紧把这些模那个截图都给记下来
Shure: I better take screenshots of these modules.
Shure: 是吧然后到时候证明我的材料对
Shure: Right, then I'll have proof for my materials.
Lucia: 而且这个沙滩很光滑
Lucia: Plus, this beach is very smooth.
Lucia: 然后就更容易掉了烦死了
Lucia: So it's easier to fall off, it's so annoying.
其他人：请问骆驼每期为什么要花400块钱
Others: Why does the camel spend 400 bucks every period?
Shure: 创二楼
Shure: Create a second floor.
其他人：那不是创造才才发现这个问题的吗
Others: Wasn't this problem discovered during the creation?
Shure: 我来了我来
Shure: I'm here, I'm here.
Shure: 我冲我冲哥
Shure: I'm charging, brother.
Shure: 我先充个10块行不
Shure: I'll charge 10 bucks first, okay?
其他人：这个是因为学姐她扣了我6分表示i'm sorry
Others: That's because the senior deducted 6 points from me, saying "I'm sorry".
其他人：i'm sorry  卧槽
Others: I'm sorry, what the heck.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 怎么还有人3月份的那个icloud车钱没
Shure: How come someone hasn't paid the iCloud fee for March?
Shure: 没交呢
Shure: Hasn't paid yet.
Shure: 怎么回事
Shure: What's going on?
其他人：没钱了
Others: No money left.
其他人：撤销了才是她的作用
Others: Cancelling it is her role.
Shure: 谢斌竹欠我巨款
Shure: Xie Bin Zhu owes me a huge amount.
Shure: 欠我12块8毛钱怎么办
Shure: He owes me 12.80, what do I do?
其他人：i'm sorry
Others: I'm sorry.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 你sorry有个蛋用还钱
Shure: Your sorry is useless, pay me back.
其他人：找个原曲
Others: Find the original song.
Shure: 咦我操
Shure: Oh crap.
Shure: 他不认我了
Shure: He doesn't recognize me anymore.
其他人：我应该叫啥
Others: What should I be called?
Shure: 就搜一步之遥也能搜着
Shure: Just search "A Step Away" and you can find it.
其他人：下午几点
Others: What time this afternoon?
Shure: 咚咚
Shure: Knock knock.
其他人：吃饭呗
Others: Let's eat.
Shure: 吃
Shure: Eat.
Shure: yeah
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:他们下来了吗
Alice: Did they come down?
其他人：我已经喊过了下来一个
Others: I already called them, one came down.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：这人最积极
Others: This person is the most enthusiastic.
Shure: 吃饭不积极
Shure: Not enthusiastic about eating.
Shure: 思想有问题
Shure: There's a problem with their mindset.
Jake:谢斌竹和刘帅呢
Jake: Where are Xie Bin Zhu and Choiszt?
其他人：来了来了
Others: Coming, coming.
其他人：吃饭了
Others: Time to eat.
其他人：这个这个是不是有点少
Others: Isn't this a bit too little?
Alice:站着吃
Alice: Eat while standing.
Jake:你收眼镜
Jake: Put away your glasses.
Jake:收眼镜别他妈玩了啊
Jake: Put away your glasses and stop playing.
其他人：眼镜
Others: Glasses.